this is Startalk we had a break and you
asked about how I told you how stupid
some of these questions right no and you
said I go ahead cuz you don't get to see
the quick I don't ya sobre you were like
you were like no give me a give me a
stupid question me what you're calling
your stupid question now you are not
calling a stupid maybe is gr9 you don't
know why it's deep
Oh is that possible that is very
possible air you go but not for this
question here we go uh Grieg first of
all what a name I like the grit lane
greed Lord Greek Greek as in the
composer yes pre guard Greek yes
so Greg wants to know this when Superman
farts is the gas or the wind more lethal
because he has super breath you know to
me where he could freeze things so oh
yeah so with his super farts be the same
way so I I think he eats regular food
right right and so if he eats regular
food then the anaerobic digestion of
that food that occurs in one's lower
intestine right would be creating the
you know the the smelly gases that are
associated with the the effluence --is
of the human orifices so well because
they're human but so would Superman's
have would it be extra potent one might
ask right I don't see why not because
here's what's interesting
here's something Superman would be cool
if he could do this you know his breath
can freeze things yeah seen that but
I've never seen his breath turn things
on fire no it has whereas eyes do that
the methane well because he focuses a
laser maser the methane that comes out
and out of out of but effluence is
methane is actually flammable yes it is
and that's the gas that is in the stove
if you have gas typically and in the
city you have methane coming out of your
stove all right that that lights okay so
if he could look at his own but he could
his own fire well what I'm saying
exactly so he can use his laser to light
the fart and turn into a flamethrower
I'm just invented I mean you asked me
the question so that would just kind of
look funny right he's got Bertha he
pulls down his drawers no I'm just if
you follow for him will be more
flammable right is it whatever it is in
human is super in him Chuck you're
tearing up here but that image is crazy
but it's right it is he does super thing
Chuck is crying okay you ask the
question I'm gonna say the physics and
everything so I'm saying I can't tell
you how sorry I am I okay
oh my god well Grieg oh dude you were
too funny thank you
who knew we would get all of that I said
it was a stupid question I take that
back I and we discover a new power for
Superman crap I will never get that
image out of my head every time I still
super down wit I'm gonna wait from the
potala look at it but it turned his ass
into a flamethrower that's amazing
Oh God okay all right let's come home
okay
this is Startalk